on september 9th 2015
queen elizabeth became the longest
reigning monarch in british history
surpassing the record set by her
great-great-grandmother queen victoria
and of course it follows that her eldest
son charles is the longest serving heir
apparent
and prince of wales in british history
but wait why is the crown prince of
england called the prince of wales
first a quick civics primer the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland is made up of four
co-equal countries england the large
powerful and popular older brother
scotland the second eldest with a
rebellious streak
northern ireland the quiet stepchild
that everybody kind of forgets
sorry northern ireland i hear belfast is
lovely and
lastly wales the cool and confident
younger brother
who hangs out a bit too much with his
sheep
it's this fourth country of the united
kingdom where the prince gets his name
but why is that to find out we have to
travel back
several hundred years to the european
middle ages
during the medieval period wales was not
a unified nation
it was made up of a number of small
kingdoms that sometimes
fought with one another and sometimes
banded together to fight off their big
scary neighbor to the east
the most powerful kingdom was gwyneth in
north wales
which was controlled by the house of
aberfra the first princes of wales came
from this
royal family who the first prince of
wales was
depends on who you ask according to
later welsh chroniclers
the first prince was a wayne gwyneth
though english sources would say
otherwise and will later
get to y he was the king of gwyneth in
the
mid-12th century and through a mix of
diplomacy and
war became the most powerful king in
wales
that being said he never used the term
prince of wales during his lifetime
jumping forward two generations we have
llewellyn the great
owain's kingdom had been divided amongst
his two sons
who by and large seemed not to have done
a great job administering it
after his uncle's deaths llewellyn came
to power
and consolidated the divided kingdoms
into one
over his reign he like his grandfather
before him
became the most powerful king in wales
and in 1216
the council of abradovi was held
it established llewellyn as the overlord
of wales
with the other welsh kings swearing
fealty to him
a few years later the king of england at
this point a young henry iii
signed the treaty of worcestershire
creating the principality of wales
with llewellyn as its leader the
principality of wales theoretically
included all of the welsh lands but the
other welsh rulers
as well as the english marcher lords
were not required to give up their lands
or
autonomy they were required however to
swear
fealty to llewellen and in turn
llewellyn swore fealty to the king of
england
so while llewellyn was the first ruler
of the principality
he was not actually called the prince of
wales in his lifetime
according to english records this was
because
in the treaty it was agreed that
llewellyn's heirs would hold the title
of prince of wales
but not lowell and himself speaking of
heirs
in 1240 llewellyn died and his son
davith succeeded him becoming the first
official
no one doubts it prince of wales he died
without any children
so his nephew llewellyn ap griffith took
the throne
he has come to be known as llewellyn the
last
and i think you can see where this is
going
well lewellen had an eventually amicable
relationship with henry iii
when henry died his son edward took the
throne of england
and things changed after a number of
political disagreements
prince llewellyn refused to pay fealty
to king edward
not liking this show of disrespect
edward declared war
on llewellyn in 1277 and so
started the conquest of wales
the war was in two stages first in 1277
edward and his forces were able to take
most of the land of wales the minor
kingdoms in the south
surrendered immediately and llewellyn
was left with just the western part
of gwyneth after such a defeat the
prince agreed to a peace treaty
in which england would keep all of its
conquered lands
but llewellyn would keep his title as
prince
a few years later however in 1282
llewellyn and his brother
david started a revolt in wales
and many of the conquered welsh lords
having grown discontented with english
rule
joined in the fight in response edward
launched a
three-pronged assault at north wales and
after a year of fighting
conquered it at the battle of orowin
bridge
llewellyn was separated from his men
cornered
and killed his head was put on a pike
in front of the tower of london harsh
his brother tried to keep the fight
going but only a couple months later
he too was captured and killed so end
the line of abber fra princes of wales
in 1301 edward who had
personally kept the principality in his
direct
control gave the lands as well as the
title
prince of wales to his son and heir
edward of canarfin
later called edward ii and so started
the tradition of english sovereigns
granting their
heir the title of prince of wales and
this is why
the english start their count of princes
at david
app llewellyn instead of owen or
llewellyn the great
because in their minds the title was
always one that the english crown had
authority over
as outlined in the treaty of
worcestershire
the local welsh population has had
different reactions to this arrangement
throughout history
there were a number of uprisings the
most famous being
in 1400 led by wayne glen dower
who claimed the title prince of wales
but after wales was incorporated into
the kingdom of
england in 1536 the welsh
seemed to accept the new princes of
wales and some
even took pride that the title was part
of the english royal family
with the rise of welsh nationalism in
the 19th century however
the title became a sore spot once again
prince charles in an effort to
calm the tide of welsh nationalism in
the 1960s
spent a year studying in wales and gave
his speech at his investiture
in welsh he has also made an effort to
stay connected to the welsh public
ever since thank you so much for
watching
please like comment or share the video
if you liked it
and subscribe and hit the bell icon to
be notified whenever we upload a new
video
bye